we're on problem 17 they still want us
to do some sequences and series what is
the nth term in the arithmetic series
below which means that that just
increases by a constant amount every
term so let's think about it a little
bit the first term right the first term
is 3 and then we increment it by 4 each
time let me write all of it is 3 and
then we go to 7 then we go to 11 and
then we go to 15 then we go to 19 right
so we go 3 and we adding 4 every time
adding 4 every time right so you get the
sense that each term in the sequence is
going to be 4 times 4 times the nth term
right but that doesn't quite work out so
I've had 4 times if this is the first
time four times the first term is 1 and
3 is less than 1 and then 4 times 2 is 8
and 7 is less than 8 and 4 times 3 is 12
but this is 1 less than 12 right so it
seems like all of these are 1 less than
a multiple of 4 so the nth term is going
to be 4 and minus 1 and that should work
out right the third term is 4 times 3 12
minus 1 is 11 and that's the third term
so that's 4 n minus 1 which is choice D
D next problem problem 71 let me copy
and paste it I'll copy and paste all of
them
all right which expression represents F
of G of X if f of X is equal to x
squared minus 1 and G of X is equal to X
plus 3 so a lot of times these seem
daunting but when you get used to it
these tend to be that these kind of
become kind of fun problems so f of G of
X means an f of X everywhere where you
see an X you have to replace it with G
of X so f of G of X is equal to G of x
squared G of x squared minus 1 right now
all I did is if I said f of dog wherever
I see an X I would replace so f of dog
would be dog squared minus 1 whatever I
see it X I just replace it with whatever
I input in right there so they want to
know F of G of X I stick a G of X in
there so it's going to be G of x squared
minus 1
well what's G of X well G of X is X plus
3 so this is going to be equal to X plus
3 squared minus 1 which is equal to x
squared the X of let's sees plus 6x plus
9 minus 1 which is equal to x squared
plus 6x minus sorry plus 8 which is
choice B B next question given that f of
X is equal to 3x squared minus 4 and G
of X is equal to 2x minus 6 what is G of
f of 2 well here instead of here you
know since they gave us an actual number
so they didn't leave it abstract we
could figure out what F of 2 is and then
put it in and then pop it into G so
what's F of 2 if you can read yeah you
should be able to see that color F of 2
wherever you see an X you replace it
with a 2 so that equals 3 times 2
squared minus 4 which is equal to 3
times 2 squared 2 squared is 4 times 3
is 12 minus 4 is equal to 8 so f of 2 is
equal to 8 F of 2 is equal to 8 so G of
F of 2 is equal to G of 8 right
and what's G of 8 G of 8 everywhere you
see an X just pop it in 8 is equal to 2
times 8 minus 6 is equal to 16 minus 6
which is equal to 10 choice D problem 73
if f of X is equal to x squared plus 2x
plus 1 and G of X is equal to 3 times X
plus 1 squared which is the equivalent
form of f of X plus G of X so
essentially they just want us to add
these two functions right so if we say f
of X plus G of X let me do that f of X
and I'll do it another color plus G of X
well now we just add them what's F of X
f of X is x squared I'll do it down here
x squared plus 2x plus 1 that's f of X
and we're gonna add G of X to that plus
oh I see why it's a little they want us
you know G of X you kind of have to
expand this out so G of X is 3 times X
plus 1 squared well that's 3 times x
squared plus 2x plus 1 but then from
here we just have to simplify this all
out and I'll do that in a third neutral
color no no no cancel do this brown
color x squared plus 2x plus 1 plus
distribute the three 3x squared plus 6x
plus 3 and now let's see you have an x
squared and a 3x squared you add those
together you get 4x squared and then I
have a 2x and have a 6x add those
together I get plus 8x and I have a 1
and I have a 3 so plus 4 4x squared plus
8x plus 4 and that's choice C next
problem in the next page
all right let me see what do they want
us to do here a math teacher is randomly
distributing 15 rulers with centimeter
Labour's labels and 10 rulers without
centimeter labels all right what is the
probability that the first ruler she
hands out will have centimeter labels
and the second ruler will not have
centimeter labels so okay let's think
about the first one let's I'll do that
in I'll color coded so what is it
probability that the first rule she
hands out will have center-weighted
first ruler she hands out will have
centimeter labels right so there's a
total of 25 total rulers right 15 widths
centimeters and 10 without at least
initially there's a total of 25 rulers
and they want to know that the first
ruler she hands out will have centimeter
labor labels so 15 have centimeter so
that probability is 15 over 25 that's
the probability of the first one be
having centimeter labels probability of
first with labels that's that one okay
but they want to know the first one
having centimeter labels and the second
ruler not having and you can't see that
highlight color and the second ruler
will not have it so this is so you're
gonna have to multiply the probability
of the first ruler times the probability
that the second not without labels so
without labels and now this is a key
given that the first ruler had labels
given that first ruler with labels now
this might all seem really complicated
with the with the notation but when you
think of it intuitively it should
hopefully make some sense I've given
away so the first ruler there was a 15
out of 25 chance that I've I've given a
ruler with labels now on the second
ruler since both of these things have to
happen I can assume that I've got a
given away the first rule are having
labels right so how many rulers do I
have now well I definitely have 24 of
rulers left and now how many of these do
not have labels
well the first ruler I gave away had a
label so I still have 10 rulers that do
not have a label right if you if you
wanted to ask the opposite question you
said what is the probability that the
first two ones that I hand out have
labels it would be 15 over 25 times 14
over 24
but because the labels would have been
decremented off to the first one because
we're assuming we have to say both of
these things happen now we're saying
okay we're gonna have one less ruler but
I have introduced a number of rulers
without labels but anyway let's just
simplify this out this becomes 15 times
10 divided by 25 times 24 we can do a
lot of canceling so we don't have to
multiplicity divide that by 3 you get 3
divide that by 3 you get 5 divide that
by 5 you get 1 divide that by 5 you get
2 3 times 2 is 6 so this is equal to 6
over 24 which is equal to 1/4 which is
choice a choice a next problem
let's see problem 75 on a certain day
the chance of rain is 80% in San
Francisco and 30% in Sydney fair enough
assume that the chance of rain in the
two cities is independent what is the
probability that it will not rain in
either city okay so it's going to be the
probability probability of not rain not
in San Francisco times the probability
of not in Sydney right because we have
to have both of these things happening
and they're independent so the
probabilities will be multiplying so
what's the probability of not having
rain in San Francisco they gave us the
chance of having rain as 80% so the
probability of not having rain is 20% or
I like to stick to the fractions 20% is
1/5 right there's a 1/5 probability of
not having rain what's the probability
of not having rain in Sydney it's 30%
actually I probably should have stayed
in decimal world so let's say it's 20%
in San Francisco 20% in San Francisco of
not having rain and the probability of
Sydney of not having rain is 1 minus 30%
or 0.7 percent or sorry or 0.7 which is
70 percent of not hat chance of not
having rain and that is equal to 2 times
7 is 14 if two numbers behind the
decimal point so there's a 14% chance
that it will not rain in either city and
that is choice B that is choice B next
problem
well actually I'm out of time see in the
next video